thank you
foreign
series of refutational videos
against one Patrick David an individual
who's notorious in social media and has
his own podcast where he has various
guests
now this particular person has actually
changed his mind on some key issues and
I wanted to bring this to the fore and
give him credit for that actually
because a lot of people will find it
difficult to do this let's take a look
at some before and after Clips wherein
before he would in my characterization
at least
um hyper generalize in a low resolution
way the status of Muslim terrorists or
terrorism in Islam or terrorism Muslims
and then afterwards he corrects himself
let's take a look at the before and the
after in a Muslim religion as much as
people in America want to make it it's a
very peaceful thing you've heard Bill
Maher say this before what bill says
most Muslims are not terrorists but Bill
Maher also says most terrorists are
Muslims right well he's not wrong first
thing we think about is also Muslim
extremist I mean every Muslim is a
Muslim extremist which is not it's a
smaller sect of the majority so recently
he's had another guest where he was
talking uh about Islam again and he
asked a very pertinent question to which
in my opinion he received an
unsatisfactory reply from his guest
let's take a look at the question that
he asked what are they doing that their
messaging is more attractive for NBA
players football players Hollywood some
people are starting to say well I'm kind
of going to lean towards this then
Christianity today so as you can see
he's asking what is it their messaging
okay now first and foremost is I think
what's happening here whether it's
intentional or unintentional there is a
kind of equivocation going on between
Islam as a religion okay and the Muslim
people or Islam as a civilization these
are three different things or usages of
the word Islam historians for example
when they were used the word Islam they
talk about Islam as a civilization okay
but then Muslims are the practitioners
of Islam what are they doing their
messaging it's not really that Muslims
have a messaging or a PR campaign or
that we're all coming together and
saying this is what we're going to say
it's just that there is a simple Message
of Islam and that is to believe in one
God to believe that there's only one God
worthy of worship if you want to
juxtapose this or compare this or
contrast this with Christianity then
clearly the main difference here is that
we don't believe Jesus Is God or the Son
of God we don't believe in the Trinity
these are the main theological
differences between Islam and
Christianity in a nutshell but of course
there are many other things as well
which one can research we've had lots of
discussions about on this very Channel
suffice it for me to say that the
theological messaging is very different
relating to the status of God we believe
in one God worthy of worship Christians
believe that there are three Persons Of
God the father of the son of the Holy
Spirit if you look at the data why
people convert to Islam this is one of
the most oft repeated off-sighted
reasons why people do so and then of
course there are these other things
social norms the moral code there are
the you know very clear
or lines red lines
boundaries that Allah God has set for us
which people
find attractive and appealing because it
gives them a sense of purpose and of
course purpose itself is something which
Islam aims to give
but having said this now I think the the
guests
he missed the boat when he was answering
the question he said that Islam provides
strong patriarchal uh response to say
feminism but if this was the case if
this is the main reason why people
convert to Islam then why not convert to
Orthodox Judaism
um Orthodox Judaism has very many
similar laws when it comes to the family
and traditional nuclear homes and so on
so why not Orthodox Judaism that is
because there are key differences
between Islam which is an evangelizing
proselytizing religion a Cosmopolitan
religion and Judaism which isn't any of
those things in any of the same way that
Islam is let's take a look at another
thing now another segment which I found
quite problematic let's say with what
Patrick Bet David has stated about the
media in Islam but at the same time the
media will defend Muslim but the media
will not defend Christianity the the
sports teams will say Hey you have to be
a little bit more under understanding
about the Muslim religion about
Christianity they can give shots so on
the point of media representation of
Muslims I think is completely
problematic and zishan from Spartan
General has made a video in this segment
he talks about Georgia State University
has actually brought a study about media
representation uh of Muslims and how
it's actually on the whole quite
negative and that is why many of the
maybe misconceptions that he initially
had before he changed his mind were were
present in the first place because of
negative media representation but the
issue of sports is even more unusual I
know he made a very specific point about
teams and so on maybe he's talking about
NFL teams or NBA teams in the American
context but it's unusual but not least
because if you look at the main
kind of uh institutions Sports
institutions and organizations FIFA the
Olympics
and so on I would I would pause it I
would submit that actually almost all of
them are disfavorable to Muslim nations
Muslim countries Muslim teams how so for
example look at the Olympics it's
divided into the Summer Olympics and
then you've got the Winter Olympics the
Winter Olympics in and of itself
excludes the majority of Muslim
countries because of the fact that most
of those countries are not even in a
climate where you could do things like
skiing and so on so it's already
exclusionary uh to the majority of the
Muslim World 60 countries are Muslim
majority then once again look at FIFA
the majority of World Cups for example
of the ones that have actually been
hosted were hosted in in Western Nations
or Latin America I mean it's it's been
for the most part Europe or Latin
America and the home field advantage is
very real as we've seen Qatar recently
which is a Muslim country the first time
a Middle Eastern country and I think the
first time Muslim country is ever you
know hosted a World Cup and you saw
completely different results with
Morocco a Muslim country reaching the
semi-finals so the point is this wasn't
the case of all the World Cups that
happened you only find
um a few of them which favor the Muslim
interest so you've got the Olympics
you've got the FIFA World Cup which are
the two biggest tournaments in sports
and they're controlled by American
businessmen and so on or european
businessmen for the most part
and that's one aspect and then you've
got in popular American culture which
you'll be very familiar with I remember
growing up and seeing a character on the
WWE uh the World Wrestling organization
called Muhammad Hassan and this was a
particular wrestler who when he came out
played the part of a terrorist actually
and there was actually one segment where
when it came out uh many of you would
have remembered in WWE
uh he came with terrorists and so on so
much so that the television station had
to ban this character from appearing
ever again it was a scandalous event so
post 911 I would argue in sports uh and
in general look at the Qatar situation
where you had all of these people uh you
know all these teams coming and talking
about Gary lineker and all these pundits
from across the world attacking Qatar
trying to get them uh to be on the mind
in some way so the the argument is not
really there I have to say Patrick I I'm
not following the argument that you're
making here uh in terms of sports and
representation of Islam and Islam being
represented however I will agree with
the guests when he said that
Christianity and Christian Figures were
also being depicted in a backward Manner
and that is of course after 1960s and
the guess was correct here in saying
that there was now a shift towards
individualism and social liberalism
something I cover in a small book that
you can get for free called the
scientific deceptions of the new
atheists but having said this I think
it's good that Patrick is now moving in
the trajectory of understanding the
other side I hope that trajectory
continues